قاتل ماجور لكنه شخص لائق بهذه الكلمات
وصفت النجمه العالميه انجلينا جولي شخصا
استاجرته عندما كانت في التاسعه عشر من
عمرها وذلك لاجل قتلها وتخليصها من عذابها
كما قالت النجم العالميه اثارت حلا من
الصدمه بين محبيها بعد اعترافها بان فكره
التخلص من حياتها سيطرت عليها في وقت سابق
لدرجه استاجرت احدهم لكي لا تلجا الانتحار
القاتل اللائق طلب من انجلينا التفكير قبل
ان تقدم على هذه الخطوه واكده انها تنتظر
لمده شهرين قبل المضيف هذه الخطوه المميته
جولي ذكرت انها كانت تعاني من صراعات
طويله بصحتها النفسيه زادت مع الشهره
والاضواء لكنها تجاوزتها فيما بعد لتصبح
من اكثر المشاهير انفتاحا على نقاشات حياه
الانسان ومشاكله الصحيه والنفسيه
[موسيقى]